president trump will travel to north
dakota today to make his case for tax
reform the president met yesterday at
the white house with the so-called big
six group of congressional leaders and
administration officials
they discussed the upcoming legislative
agenda including tax reform margaret
brennan is at the white house margaret
good morning
good morning well the president has
pledged to make the tax code as simple
as possible but it's really unclear what
that's going to look like congress will
have to decide if they can deliver on
promised tax cuts to both big top
earners and middle class families now in
order to do this and reform the tax code
the white house is going to need broad
support including from democrats and
that's why the president is bringing
north dakota senator heidi heitkamp with
him on air force one today white house
officials say she is the first democrat
to join his tax reform push the white
house is targeting states like north
dakota and missouri before that in order
to sell the tax package because mr trump
won those states in 2016 and the sitting
senators there are vulnerable facing
tough reelection battles next year white
house officials do concede now that they
are unlikely to deliver on a promised
corporate tax rate cut from 35 percent
down to as low as 15 percent and after
the failure to repeal and replace
obamacare all of this has gotten much
more difficult white house officials
nora they do say on this issue the
president will remain personally engaged
on a weekly basis all right margaret
thank you so much